we're joined by the legendary scott
adkins he's done a backflip
i've done that one in a home movie that
i made
the first time i fought jackie chan oh
there's a story behind that i need to
tell you
thanks to raycon for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to see how
you can get 15 off
this is atrocious
oh man scott we love you but as a
brother we want to make fun of you a
little bit
hey everybody we are back with another
wonderful episode of stuntman react
beard joined by the legendary scott
adkins he actually came out and joined
us this is
super cool i'm actually a little nervous
um
well listen guys i i'm a fan of the show
i have to shame eric's not here so i'll
get my own back on him but never mind
well we have some amazing clips we're
going to be jumping into today you
fought against some of the most
legendary martial arts stars of of all
time you know donnie yen tony i can't
wait to hear what those experiences were
like but i also really want to dig into
some of your fights and your experiences
and like the stories that you have from
your years of working in the business my
very first martial arts job was with
your uncle no [ __ ] yeah it was a teaser
trailer for black mask too it's a
pre-sale yeah yeah yeah and he worked me
so hard
that i was almost physically sick
that's the only time i've ever worked
with him yeah
[Laughter]
why are we starting with the one where i
get the [ __ ] kicked out
yeah i noticed your propensity for uh
being cast as a bad guy a couple times
here i gotta say you have a very high
level beard and i think the more high
level your beard game is the better you
are being cast or a villain
this is for my new villainous path
i love how he barely flinches when you
throw that first punch to test the range
look how cool he is
donnie yen the legend you know for me to
be in like uh what is a modern day kung
fu movie was a big thrill because that's
what you grew up watching and they don't
make as many as they used to but it's
been something like this which is like
the the best sort of kung fu franchise
of modern day times what a thrill
it's not easy when you walk in on day
three aching and they say
ah today's the day for all the kicks
day three is always the worst you know
because you're doing it all day you're
doing it for 12 hours and you're full on
and that's the thing if you're a fighter
which i'm not but you know you go in
there for 25 minutes you do your thing
that's it you're done but the thing
about making films is you're doing it
for 12 hours and you can't stay warm for
the whole time you're gonna cool down
and that's when you get the little
tweaks and the injuries and then day two
day three day four those tweaks are
turning into proper problems that you've
got to deal with you know
i always see that bit where i do the
back kick it looks like my uh trousers
have blown apart but they haven't
or maybe i'm always just checking out my
ass
no it's not there but i always just
see the split in the pants for some
reason because that happens to me a lot
in real life oh i gotta imagine
cause i'm always going around trying
kicks at people
that's true what are your pants
considerations you must be like you
gotta reinforce them it is a
consideration yeah it's something you
have to think about
it's funny because the the fight is not
choreographed beforehand in hong kong
they do on the spot and i know i'm the
bad guy and i know he's gonna kick my
ass but i'm thinking well how is he
going to kick my ass what is going to be
my fate and at this point when they were
explaining that they're breaking my arm
and then he punches you in the face and
then then he hits you in the throat and
then hits you in the nuts and i'm
thinking could i go out like any more of
a [ __ ]
this is terrible
but that's just the way they do in hong
kong very organic but you have to be
ready as a performer to be shown the
choreography there and then and you
watch it and you've got to pick it up
pretty quick and then you've got to get
in there with donnie yen one of the best
guys ever
and do it uh you know 100 percent speed
and know that carl would feel like that
it's a stressful situation how many
takes does it take down the end to learn
his choreography no he's
just immediately
it's that's the level these guys are the
pinnacle of of making martial arts fight
scenes
oh there's a story behind that i need to
tell you so the shot is he punches me
and then i go back and i kick him in the
chest tony comes up to me and he's like
i can just be this close to you when i
punch you and then you're going to move
back and
in the rehearsal he did it so fast and
it just literally touched my cheek and
i'm like
man
and so on tate number one
he hits me in the face really hard
it's like
and then i've ended the kick
and he's like no you've gotta you've
gotta once you get hit in the face then
you kick my chest i'm like yeah yeah but
okay
he does the punch and i rush the kick
and i kick him straight in the throat
and that's the one that they've used
straight in the throat and he's like ah
you kidding me
and it's donnie yen you know
he was fine but then what they did is
they put the camera over my shoulder and
he's going to do the punch now and i've
just kissed him
and i'm thinking to myself he's just
gonna he's just gonna smack me now it's
payback time so i've accepted my fate
and i'm just waiting for him to blast me
in the face all i can say is
thank you donny
thank you for not blasting the face
after i kicked you in the throat
i love it when you get a heart here it
looks fantastic and you know to be on
the receiving end of that is another
thing but if a stuntman comes up to me
and says i'll take i'll take a proper
hit for you scott i i'm not going to
turn it down okay and i'll say great
mate just put your face right there
and we're going to smash it
for a second
but it you know you can never you should
never do that to a stunt guy that's not
expecting it you know that's not ethical
it's not cool but those guys that
occasionally says i'm going to take one
for the team there i'm going to i'm
going to give give one to the gods of
action it's like yeah come on because
that it looks great i love it when you
see tony job blast someone donnie and
samuel hung there are those moments
where they hit people hard have you ever
volunteered to take a hard hit for for
the camera
i remember on the shepherd
saying to van damme sidekick me as hard
as you can
and uh
he's like no no i'm not going to do that
i said no it's fine because the time
it's like yeah come on give me your best
shot i can take it and i'm offering it
to you sean claude because you're my
hero so please just smack me as hard as
you can
[Music]
so remember that
[Laughter]
and you've fought
so many big names in the world of
martial arts cinema
yeah pretty much uh everyone except for
bruce lee have you had jet li yeah
unleashed
like the first time i fought jackie chan
was in a film called the medallion i'm
fighting him on this boat and i knew
that if i did a good job as the henchman
for this little piece of the fight that
they were going to give me the big end
fight with jackie chan so there's a bit
where we throw these punches and i've
got to do this back kick but i remember
just being so stressed out because it's
jackie chan you know in his first film
we're done with him you know i mean he
doesn't want some jackass coming in and
blasting him with the back yeah so it's
very stressful so on the first take i
hit him too lightly
samo hangs to fight coordinator and i
hear him shouting over from the back
more power
and then one of jackie chan's stunt team
come up to me and i say
be very careful
oh no so i've got some of that
and i've got the stunt team looking at
me
[Laughter]
so scott you were one of the most
requested guests on our show and
somehow through the power of the
comments you have manifested yourself
into this space i came through the
comments
[Music]
so if there's somebody else you would
really like to have on this show please
leave a comment below suggesting them
[Music]
i was so about equilibrium when i was 16
years old it's gun qatar isn't it yeah
it's complete fast it's all sorts of
goofy
the the thing that you gotta give
christian bill credit for is he is
acting his ass off
he's bought in so hard he's just trying
to remember the choreography it's not
his fault
this movie was designed to
hit every neuron in a teenage boy's mind
[Laughter]
definitely inspired by john woo isn't it
yeah did i love john moo yeah john wu
captures a bit of that samo hung jackie
chan um like world of action but he's
not martial arts he's into you know the
gun play and the pyrotechnics and
special effects well he came from making
martial arts films there were a lot of
swordplay movies that he made and if you
look at his the way he uses the gun it's
like the gun is an extension of your
hand as if
a sword is yeah so you know the way he's
using the guns like that i mean
obviously it doesn't make any sense in
terms of your aim you're the only other
person who's ever said that because i
thought about that when i saw the
hard-boiled because you know with a gun
you're trying to not be where the gun is
pointing right so it's just like a sword
you don't want to be where the sword is
pointing and you know you can see that
in the choreography and i've never heard
anybody else put it into words except
for you
[Laughter]
you know what's up
that same extension john mc1 very much
was using the gun as essentially an
explosive close range punch right the
trick that they figured out i think for
the john wick movies was they were like
we compress it and we go very close
quarters with and we treat gunshots and
gun play as essentially punches it's the
same concept as a fight scene it's cause
and effect so in a fight scene you see
the punch hit the guy you see the guy
reacts all in one shot with the gun you
see the gun fire and you see the guy
getting shot in the same shot yeah you
put an edit in there and cut to the guy
getting the shot it's just not as good
sergio leone when he came out with the
good the badly ugly they would never
show the guy getting shot the gun and
the guy getting shot in the same shot
before that but he didn't know about
that so it was quite shocking to see the
gun and the guy getting shot in the same
but you know everyone loved it because
it was just yeah more visceral and just
looked amazing and that's what john woo
does essentially it's a lot of cause and
effect all the just [ __ ] blowing up
around that
yeah chaos yeah
right this is a 1989 samur hung directed
movie called pedicab driver with some
brilliant fights and samo he's known for
hitting people hard yeah
[Music]
his whole body gets off the ground now
watch this guy next what's the next guy
[Music]
it's panning across there as he gets hit
and here it's going back there and back
here again
it's all very interesting
watch this [ __ ]
that'll get you out of that situation
guaranteed
[Music]
it's just brilliant it's the this is the
golden age this is when action for me
was at its very best and i don't think
it's it's going to be equaled the the
effort the quality of the stunts the
physical stunts that you wouldn't do now
because you can do cg and everything but
they're just putting their bodies on the
line back then because there was no
other way of doing it other than you've
got to do it in camera
and in those days in hong kong it wasn't
about you know car chases and big
explosions because they didn't have the
budget that you know hollywood had it
was all about
fighting yeah and physical stunts
and that's why you got those crazy
stunts where it looks like people have
died because that's that's what how they
were trying to up the ante and compete
with hollywood movies so i don't think
we'll get it again with cg and
everything the superhero movies they
take care of that quota right yeah
you're getting to see your fight scenes
and action stuff in the superhero movies
so there's less martial arts movies but
then you've got stuff like john wick
and you've got these directors coming
through now that have come from the
world of stunts right like sam hargrove
with extraction chadstichowski john wick
david leach deadpool 2 and hobson shaw
so we're getting these new guys coming
through from the stunt world that
understand this
and they're putting their version of it
so actually
it's looking pretty good
to have a professional who is so well
versed in this world share their
knowledge with us
it's a it's a it's a gift and scott
actually has a whole youtube channel
it's uh the art of action scott atkins
the art of action there's a link in the
description below if you like this show
you definitely need to go check it out
because it is scott talking with some of
the most accomplished martial artists
and stunt men actors stunt women in the
world today
and revealing really in-depth insights
so if you enjoy the show you think this
is cool well go check out scott's show
because it's it's this but even more
it's like this
but better
there it is
as you can see i'm not a stunt guy as
much as i'd like to be pretty cool i've
tried but no
i'm here to talk about today's sponsor
raycon raycon's out there disrupting the
industry making earbuds that are half
the cost of other premium audio brands
they're really small they're really
compact they're noise isolating so
they'll literally sit in your little ear
canal and block out all of the sound
from around you so if you like to ride
your bike through the wilderness raycon
is for you there's no dangling wires you
got a bunch of different fits and sizes
also they come in a bunch of different
colors i know you might be all about
that bass well guess what these raycons
will give you six hours of that base and
let's say you don't want them anymore
you need something different well you
got a 45 day free return policy click
that link in the description or head on
over to buy raycon.com coral crew and
you will get 15 off your first purchase
of recon earbuds it's a pretty sweet
deal that's 15 off if you go to buy
raycon.com corridor crew or just click
that link in the description
well scott thank you so much really
appreciate it freddie
always a good time thanks for joining us
no problem thanks for having me nico can
i just say that it's an absolute
pleasure to be on i watch the show a lot
you guys doing a great job keep it up i
i've learned quite a few things myself
and i thought that i knew everything so
thanks guys